Film Courage: Paul you went to USC and took
screenwriting at USC? Paul Gulino, Professor at Chapman University Dodge College: Correct. Actually
Columbia
I studied screenwriting at Columbia
University and I taught at USC for five
years during the 90s. I was a originally
a English major than a history major at
Columbia as an undergraduate history was
about stories about people doing things
so there was maybe a natural inclination
there and then while I was an undergrad
we used to take our super 8 sound camera
and make comedy shorts and this is your
audience may not remember this but there
was a time when movies were shown in
front of big audiences not on a little
screen and if you were working in comedy
it's very useful to show your stuff and
from an audience and find out what's
working what isn't so we would do that
we were making movies having fun and
then when I was an undergrad I met Frank
Danielle who took over the film program
at Columbia along with Milos Forman a
director who was his former student and
I met Frank Danielle took a class with
him and it was it was something of a
revelation his approach I sensibly sat
in on it I wasn't supposed to be there
but he let me do everything and write it
was a Writing Workshop and so I wound up
staying there to study as a grad student
at Columbia with with Frank Danielle and
then when went out there and started
writing doing my thing working both in
theater and trying to write screenplays
and then moved when I moved to
California was able to sell a screenplay
again started with that and then the I'd
always was interested in teaching
because I had a good role model in Frank
Danielle but I didn't feel like I should
teach until I'd actually sold something
and maybe got something made because if
it's like it validates the approach that
you've been taught that you would then
teach
then I got an offer to teach a USC and I
thought well I haven't sold anything and
then I realized oh I have sold something
yes I would like to teach so I wound up
teaching there from 93 to 98 and that
was a great experience great students
and then in 98 I had an offer to come to
Chapman University and the film program
was getting under way it had been
existing for a little while but it had
become a separate film school in 96 so I
was just getting there - I was the first
screenwriting professor that they they
hired and so I've been at Chapman ever
since what were your notions of selling
a screenplay when you were undergrad at
Columbia versus once you had already
been established at USC come to dodge
College
well the to sell a screenplay I guess
you mean when I was a grad student when
I was an undergrad I didn't know the
scripts our movies are written I didn't
know that sure what were some of your
earlier notions of selling a screenplay
and what would be like to be a working
screenwriter versus having been whether
it be in the trenches or teaching or
around career screenwriters well from
the get-go I was interested in I guess
you could say connecting with an
audience okay so that's the impulse and
I saw myself as a filmmaker and not a
screenwriter and Frank Daniel's notion
was that it's the same thing that a film
is made before it's shot it's made on
paper first and a screenplay as a
conception of a movie is the equivalent
of filmmaking in fact Alfred Hitchcock
was once quoted as saying he was the
writer told me this the writer of psycho
said that when they collaborated on the
movie psycho the script and and the
final meeting was just a formality with
the producer or they were done with the
project he said Alfred Hitchcock looked
really depressed and the writer asked
him so
what's wrong is something wrong in the
script you said no the script is fine
now I have to go shoot it so that idea
of being a filmmaker was what motivated
me now in terms of the market back then
it's what I understood back then and I
don't think it's really any different
now is that there's nothing you can do
to sell a screenplay
there's only things that you can do that
increase the likelihood of it because
there's so many variables and we were
what my approach was I guess I called it
the corporate sneak-attack approach I
thought okay I'm a writer I think I've
gained a lot of skill with this teacher
but in order to connect with someone who
can actually read it I need to get into
the industry so I took the first job in
the industry act again which was at
Showtime
and that was about maybe six months
after I graduated you know did temping
for a while in New York City and then
was able to get a full-time job there
just as a secretary but I was able in
that job to meet everybody in the
company because I floated I was like a
permanent temp floating around and
meeting pretty much everybody in the
company as I worked in the different
departments and then was able to
eventually do script reading and then by
that means meet an agent so you're
asking what was the approach to selling
a screenplay any number of things can
happen but my strategy was to try to
make connections through work and get
someone to read the script
and that's how I did it I also would
just send out postcards to agents
describing my background and also I got
recognition from a fest from a contest
the nickel fellowship and the writers
guild had a fellowship so I said okay
I've been recognized read my stuff and
just keeping on going persisting and
trying also to keep on with the craft
now it was a day job but my ideal
schedule that I tried to keep was wake
up at 5:00 in the morning go for a quick
run and right for a couple hours and
then go to work at 9:00 and Coast the
rest of the day because the important
stuff was done one bit of advice that I
always followed that Frank Danielle had
suggested he said and I think Lawrence
Kasdan the writer director also had a
similar idea he said don't get a job
when you do your day job and you're
earning your they're paying your dues
don't get a job that's somewhat creative
because it could be it can satisfied
your creative impulse and then you you
won't be as passionate about your
writing so for example don't go into
copywriting for PR advertising don't go
into marketing things where you're gonna
write copy or publicity or whatever the
areas might have that because you're
going to do that during the day and
you're gonna create something and then
you're gonna go home and you're not
gonna be as hungry for that so I when I
wound up settling down in at Showtime I
wound up in research which was quiet
nobody did anything except they generate
these statistical reports and I would
just sit there and write my screenplays
during the during the day as much as I
could
don't tell anybody at Showtime that I
tried to tell them I was working at hard
but you know so does that answer your
question about the market or the my
expectations for how to sell it just
write something that people don't want
to put down that grabs them they can't
put down
and then be patient and try working one
step at a time to get it out there and
to meet people that can maybe get get
something done with it and the first
writing actual job that I got was
through a friend and this is in 1990 so
there was a period of a lot of
independent low-budget stuff going on
and I had a degree in this I'd studied
with it people knew what I'd studied I
had a sample script I had a new one by a
couple of new ones that I'd done and
through that means some director was
looking for a collaborator on a rewrite
of a project and it was just somebody I
knew and so we had a few thousand
dollars and you get something and then
you just get started that way that was
the market back then and then nowadays
it's in some ways it's because of the
this outburst of output of predicted
production happening I think it's
probably a much better situation you
have I I like to say George Lucas when
he came into the industry he he said
that he felt like a seam opened up in
history a seam open and he and his
cohort got in a very special moment in
history and they were able to do these
amazing things and I feel like a seam in
history has opened up again with the
arrival of streaming and with the
internet being able to be a distribution
place and the the apparent demand for
for product now right now it's happening
whether all these streaming things
things will survive whether something
like Whidbey can really generate there's
a big enough market for a 10-minute
webisodes on your cell phone we're going
to find out but right now there they're
out there looking for material and they
have to generate it so that's a lot of
interesting things happening
from being at Showtime what did you
learn about a-flat script versus a
viable script to me I'm looking for
something it's it's pretty basic it's
does it grab me and does it keep me
however they accomplish that is it does
it flow does it have a natural flow does
it make me want to turn the pages in my
training I learned somewhat how to do
that and then in subsequent experience
and study and we talked about it in the
books the the techniques that you can
actually do there are tools you can use
to keep the audience engaged but
essentially that was it I wasn't looking
or nor was I instructed to look for any
particular type of material I was just
handed things and some of the things I
did were reading stage plays like can we
make this into a Showtime on Broadway
production would that work sometimes
they'd send me off to see a theater
group that kind of thing and I'd have to
give it a report on my judgment on that
but beyond something that grabs you and
keeps your attention I'm not that that's
pretty much it now there was one script
and I think I'll have to it'll have to
remain nameless
there was one script that I remember
from that time a couple years that I was
doing that and I thought this is funny
this is smart this is clever I sure hope
this gets made somehow and that was like
1983 okay 84 and time went on and then
sure enough it got made 20 years later I
thought oh that's great
same title but by then it had been so
rewritten that it was a famous disaster
and it was too bad but that would be an
example there was one that just the
cleverness of the writing the the way
the characters were so sharp the way it
flowed was
made me remember it it stood out in the
pile of material so interesting why do
you think so many whether it's hands got
you know in the pie or why do you think
that it had such a fresh voice and then
it was almost this is just my word but
destroyed maybe that's too strong but
well it's not too strong
it's the mode of production I think in
at least four big movies is is a problem
I think because when you have a big
movie and this wound up being a big
studio movie I just think there's so
much pressure that it work that there's
defensive things that happen and we need
to make sure that the okay I'm not sure
this draft is right let's get another
writer in and then you know there's
there's so much at stake that it it has
an effect on the product and it can
become incoherent and it is a
collaborative medium and there's always
going to be even in the best of
circumstances you could have a great
writer director producer casts and and
script and it could still fall flat its
imprecise but there seems to be the
storytelling tends to flatten out in
these situations because one of the
elements of that I talk about more in
the first book about dramatic irony
dramatic irony is of course Alfred
Hitchcock used it create suspense to
create to use to create a story that
involves withholding some information
from the audience some information from
the characters when you reveal it that
requires someone who's really watching
it and imagining it in their own mind
the whole time and if you've got a lot
of people involved somebody's gonna go
oh my goodness we sure the audience is
going to get this well you better make
it clear and if it's clear its risks
being boring the three three three
questions that Frank Danielle shared
with us that I still think apply to any
story he said there's three question
that you ask when you're crafting a
story 1 what does the main character
want and what are they trying to avoid
hey that's question 1 - what is this the
main character no and what does the main
character not know and then the third
question is what is the audience know
what is the audience not know and I
don't think most writers realize that
you have control over those second two
that the audience especially when I work
with students the audience doesn't have
to know everything all the time and the
characters don't have to know everything
all the time you can withhold some
information you can play games in fact
my takeaway from the book that Connie
and I did the science of screenwriting
see it that came out last year was this
applying constructivist psychology to
the storytelling process this is
something that was in the 80s a film
critic David Bordwell came out with a
blockbuster scholarly work in which he
squarely placed storytelling in the
realm of the constructivist psychology
and that simply means that most of our
experience in life most of our
experience of reality is based not on
knowledge but on inferences that we make
based on clues so that you have what's
called top-down processing bottom-up
processing is you see things that goes
into your brain and you make note of it
and you store information top down is
you see something in the world and your
brain automatically compares what you've
experienced before with what you're
seeing and then you make a conclusion
you know there's shortcuts that we're
doing all the time you've never seen the
back of this chair but you've seen
chairs so you assume the back kind of
looks like any other chair it would be a
surprise twist at the back of this chair
had a dragon hiding out there you know
because that's not normal what you're
normally associated with that concept so
in
when you're telling a story you're you
you if you understand that that's how
audiences are responding their house a
movie is they're looking for clues and
they're going to put them together and
they're actively involved in
constructing a reality you're the one as
a screenwriter as a storyteller you're
giving them the clues you're turning
them and get in Frank Danielle's term
you're making them the smartest people
in the world you're making them so
brilliant because they're seeing all
these clues and you're the one who's
actually giving them to them but they
think they're figuring it out and
they're gonna try to anticipate where
you're going because they've seen movies
before the this is an ocean conceptual
framework called a schema they've seen a
movie they know how movies are they know
they have tend to have a character who
does this and that and when you know
that you can play games with them and
that's the for me the most fun thing
about screenwriting is creating worlds
and driving people crazy getting in
their heads and you can learn how to get
in their heads just a very simple
example suppose I show you a movie
there's a shot of a husband and he's
buying the wife and his wife flowers and
chocolate and an anniversary card okay
and on his way home from work okay then
meanwhile you see the wife has got a gun
and she's hiding it in the bedroom
drawer okay what are you gonna think
well it's pretty obvious isn't it he's
wants to make love and she has other
plans right okay that's where the
audience is gonna go and that's you
could pay it off that he comes home with
the flowers she pulls out the gun and
shoots him or you could then disclose
later that the gun that he's gun
collector and the surprise and this is a
present for him this is a gun he's been
looking for she saved up for it and she
wants to give it to him for anniversary
present and then you find out that he
poisoned the chocolate so you we just
told a
twist is just telling two stories at the
same time the one the audience thinks
it's seeing and the one is actually seen
and you're relying when you do that kind
of thing on the audience's propensity to
figure it out and be smarter than you
and once you've got them going that way
you can have all kinds of fun so that
that's one element of the constructivist
psychology that that we mentioned in the
book and have examples of the filmmakers
doing that you know doing that kind of
thing why do two different audience
viewers see a scene in different ways
well why do they that's again relates to
constructivist psychology that we all
experience have different experiences of
the world and we bring different things
to the movie and we're gonna have
therefore different perceptions based on
our own experience I had this
interesting moment in a class once where
I had a still frame of Nurse Ratched in
one flow of the Cuckoo's Nest and it's
just after she's presided over this
rather chaotic group therapy session and
there's there's a lingering close-up of
this character and I had several
different interpretations of that look
and one was that she's a sadist and
she's happy that she destroyed all these
people the other is that she's really
upset that it didn't go better in other
words that she's empathetic same exact
image different people bringing
different things to it and so that's one
reason why it's virtually impossible to
have a movie that everybody's gonna love
or that there's one formula that that
will be universally appealing because
there are these different kinds of
experiences we have comedy is something
that is very specific to culture and
that's something else that at least got
to mention in here that comedy tends to
be very cultural specific and that's
because I
joke is a very bare-bones story and the
audience is the one that brings cultural
experience into it in order to get it so
that's why I pointed out again in the
book if you look at IMDB okay you look
at the top rated movies of all time in
their database just as a sample you
don't get to a comedy until number 30
because some people are gonna find it
funny and some people aren't drama maybe
a little more Universal in terms of what
maybe other factors involved but so yeah
the the search for a universal
universally successful formula is in
vain
in fact the other thing is that once you
have a really successful movie like Star
Wars it exists so now that's part of
people's experience so any subsequent
movie is going to be seen in relation to
Star Wars so if I do the exact same
movie again people are gonna think I saw
that already or if I do a variation and
they're gonna they might think well
that's kind of similar to Star Wars
isn't it you know it's it affects how we
experience things so the fortunately the
quest for a universal formula is is in
vain it's it's in a creative field like
this in the kind of relationship there
is between filmmaker and audience
can you explain the eight sequence
template sure this originates in two
ways two places it originates in
Hollywood history by the accident of the
one real film 35 millimeter film that
became standardized by the first decade
of the 20th century the first movies by
that by that time let's say that by 1910
there are single real experiences there
are ten minutes long and for various
reasons in the teens of Hollywood split
in two directions from the single real
film to what we call full-length
features multi real films hour and after
two hours three hours and in the other
direction to the serial which is a real
or two installments series and the
reason you have the origin of sequences
is that in the u.s. the distribution
system was so rigorously one real a week
or two reels a week that when they
started to generate full-length feature
films they were still distributed a
couple of reels a week so if you look at
manuals of the time it's been writing
manuals they're about 60 titles that
came out in the 19-teens on how to write
a photo play because the market was kind
of wide open and people wanted to write
these thing you'll get instructions
about making sure that each reel has a
climax to it so that the audience will
be interested in seeing the next reel
and then they'll see the next one after
that so it was almost like a limited
series the feature film by the late
teens we are seeing them all the
distribution system is changing and
you're seeing in theaters what we would
normally experience as a feat
full-length feature but the the idea of
writing by the reels survived into the
20s and 30s and you can see the scene
evidence of it in the way the continuity
scripts are marked they're often marked
by sequence letter sequence ABCD and
that is where what we call sequences
come the nomenclature comes from what
Frank Danielle discovered in teaching in
the 80s he discussed the three-act
structure in terms of setting up a
situation developing it and then paying
it off but he found that the students
struggled with the middle part of the
script because it's intimidating how do
you fill up 60 pages in the middle and
usually 30 pages to set it up 60 pages
in the middle and 30 pages in the third
act so he revived this idea of sequences
he said well don't think of it in terms
of one you know act of sixty pages think
of it as four 15-minute scripts that
each one builds on the last and so thus
the the sequence approach is born you're
not going to try to tackle a whole 120
pages just figure out these 15 minutes
the first one first 15 minutes and then
the next 15 minutes then that's gonna
really do some kind of major problem for
a character so then they're gonna try to
explore the next for the next 15 minutes
and the the effect is actually very
liberating because you wind up not
worrying about how you're gonna fill up
these pages but more about how you're
gonna trim them down because now you've
got all this material but it also helps
you explore a premise really fully you
have a character let's just take a
classic dramatic construction character
wants something and there's obstacles
okay if the end of the first act they we
know what they want we know what the
obstacles are gonna be well what is a
character gonna do character doesn't
know what the movies about character
just thinks oh this is this is easy I
can solve this so they try something and
that's in your conceptualization of the
story the character tries the easiest
thing that they can try and then the
filmmaker the screenwriter comes up with
an obstacle why that doesn't work
that's a baby 10-15 minutes all right so
now they got to try something else
what's that gonna be and you can develop
it and each sequence has its own
integrity ideally the the paradigm is
that each sequence is going to have
three acts also it's going to have some
kind of setup you don't have to do as
much setup because we know the
characters but you're gonna have to
introduce new circumstances they're
gonna try to get something and then it's
gonna end with some kind of resolution
usually negative because it's positive
maybe the movies over but it leads to
the next sequence and to the next one
and so you wind up with actually a kind
of a nested structure because the scenes
dramatic scenes have the same three acts
that's why I tend to like three acts you
can depends on how you define it but if
you understand it as working with
tension which tension is just putting
something in the audience's mind hope
and fear the character wants something
are they going to get it or not that's
what I'm wondering about and if I care
about the character then I'm gonna stay
tuned because I want to see the answer
to that so it's you don't need more than
three acts for that you just need to set
that up and then you need to develop it
and then you get the answer
so each act the act set up the whole
thing
then each sequence has its own ok
character wants something and there's
problems and then each scene has a
character that wants something in
there's obstacles so it's like this
iterative structure that keeps the
audience involved because we're
constantly wondering about what how it's
going to come out for the character and
one thing that we also recover in the in
the book down science of screenwriting
is this this process of connection to a
main character and what the theories are
about why we have that and it's
certainly important if you come into a
if you're at a park and you come in up
on a tennis game and two people are
really battling each other it may be
interesting but it's not gonna be
dramatic to you cause you don't know
them but if if you do know one if
one of them and you know that they just
mortgage their house and put everything
on this gain and then you know the other
person is a hustler then every child my
god you've got something that's
transformational but you have to make
that connection emotionally and so so to
get back about the sequence structure
you have many versions of the new three
acts and sequences and then in the
scenes and that is the suspense the
tension that keeps us interesting and we
also we have a chapter on the contrast
in film and that plays also into this
approach which is that in order to
maintain audience attention the stimulus
has to be changed frequently otherwise
you you zone out you you lose connection
you don't think about other things and
you need to reset the audience's brain
periodically and filmmakers do it you
can see evidence of it and changing
light and dark loud and soft fast and
slow but you also see it in tension and
release tension maintained for too long
it's tedious but if you release it and
give us a chance to reset then you can
go on and build it up again and again
and again until you reach the the
culmination of the picture and then
finally you try to release it entirely
and then people get people to say yeah I
see that movie again I'm gonna call my
friends I want to see it is it based on
a time limit actually is there an actual
science to the to the down to the minute
of what we can handle and turn what when
where our mind wanders I my
understanding us and this is something
that Connie might be able to confirm but
our attention can maybe last about three
to five minutes and then we need to re
reset it somehow and dramatic scenes
tend to be about three to five three
minutes usually about three pages and
before you need to have some new
character enters you cut away to
something you have a new development
something to scramble it up
so yeah you I I don't think in fact the
sic premise of this book the inspiration
for making your doing the science of
screenwriting was if you see patterns in
its movies and you see patterns and the
advice about movies is there a deeper
reason for it it's there a physiological
basis for it there's a there's a cartoon
and a New Yorker cartoon that has it
kind of illustrates the idea there is a
an audit or a theatre a movie theatre
and it's filled with cats okay all the
cats are the whole audience and on
screen is a shoe with a shoelace that's
loose okay so okay a cat's gonna find
that completely enthralling a human
being maybe not so much but what we do
find enthralling you're gonna see the
patterns there we are gonna look at that
we're gonna look for certain things and
be satisfied by certain things so the
physiology kind of determines what we're
what we're seeing on screen so I I kind
of see the book as it as I mentioned
it's kind of a argument subtler okay
what's fashionable what advice is
essential what isn't what do we need to
know what do we not need to know well
it's like well go back to the scientific
basis for things and see is there
something there that dictates it or is
it just an option so that that's part of
the inspiration for it
what is information dump is it a good
thing a bad thing oh well this is the
question of how do you get information
to the audience people want to know why
people on screen are doing what they're
doing in order to communicate that you
have to give them background information
get us let us know what the
circumstances of the movie are and the
question is how do you how do you convey
that information and the human mind
doesn't respond well to raw information
that's just dumped on them
we need a context to remember it and a
great example is the recipe I don't know
of anybody who gets a recipe because
they're cooking something reads it once
and then goes and does it it's a
constant what do I need now what do I
need no you know that's because it
there's no context for that information
it's just dumped on you in order for us
to get accepted information and take it
in we need it needs to be embedded in
something else and it needs to be in
little bits and pieces and so we talked
about exposition strategies which I will
be familiar to some people that people
have written about this but it's giving
us clues again and we start to figure it
out who these people are what they're
about and a puzzle is a great way to get
people to take in information pose us
something that's mysterious are curious
and right away I want to know what
what's happening what do we who are
these people and it's in a way it's like
if you want people to eat make them your
eat your dinner make sure they're hungry
you know okay get them hungry for the
information and then they're ready ready
for it ready to take it in and that
that's that's what we talk about is
information dump kind of the mirror
opposite of that would be like a screen
crawl okay this is what happened here
and here and here and
the guy Kate he was born here he raised
there the people won't remember that
Star Wars begins with that scream crawl
but they also it's part of the style of
it and all the information that's on
there gets repeated in various ways
during the course of the early part of
the story so it's actually more style
than it's necessary for anything else
you know you're probably not going to
remember that so that's that the we do
you know talk about give examples of
different kinds of strategies that
filmmakers have use to get us interested
in these things so but often movies
begin with a puzzle successful ones so
I'm kind of visual a puzzle and then we
get curious and then we want to see get
we get a little bit of information then
we get a little bit more and then
finally before we know what we're in but
the key is to smuggle the information in
in little bits preferably in the
narrative so that we don't know we're
getting that we don't know where we're
we're not aware we're getting the
information like American Beauty let's
say taking that as an example we sort of
dissect that in terms of the the puzzle
analogy right that's been a long time
since I've seen that but that begins
with that disembodied voice he's talking
and he's is he
airborne soaring over the top am I
remembering it right I believe so and
then it one at some point you see a net
benning's character she's holding like
an open house maybe right and and she's
you know she's got the realtor face on
and she's super happy Pollyanna and then
they shut the door and she kind of like
has a meltdown and then you go oh wow
this is really good yes that's well
that's giving you clues he doesn't tell
you what happens I think he says in a
year I'll be dead and that's creates
anticipation of course the key and this
is when we talk about page-turner we're
talking about anticipation I'm into it I
want to anticipate what's happening I'm
trying to figure it out that's a little
clue that gets thrown out there and it
makes us wonder in fact that's something
in the first book the screenwriting the
sequence approach it's called a deadline
I mean I didn't invent that term but
it's the term that neurologists use a
deadline is a just what it sounds in
that movie it's exactly what it is he's
going to be dead in a year but a
deadline is a certain time limit that
people are working under the characters
are working under you know I got six
days to get to X I've got to be at home
by midnight or X that's a very useful
tool the deadline but we're okay so with
American Beauty right they just give you
a little clue make us curious then you
have their the clue that suggests
somebody who's happy and then you give
us a surprise twist we learn more and
then now we're curious and the curiosity
keeps propelling us in how does the
character arrive for screenwriters is it
something that's very vivid in their
mind like almost this is a real person
even if it's not or is it a hazy vague
thing that develops over many drops I
think it ultimately it's gonna depend on
the writer and I've known writers that
work they have a great character and
they just want to see what kind of
circumstance would be right for this
character to explore in fact Frank
Danielle used to say that you could see
a story as like a scientific experiment
where you take a known substance and a
environment that you know and you put
them together and see how they react
find out what what happens you want to
find a character some people will go
with that first okay this great
character what kind of circumstance
would challenge them the most make them
explode basically and but most people
tend to come up with a story I find
first and then they explore well what
kind of character can can that be would
work for my story that I have and in
terms of how right different writers
work I know some writers will base it on
a person they know and sometimes that's
very useful
and the advantage of that even if it's
the the person they know has nothing to
do with that
a story is that you can get real
specific as you know the character you
know you know that how they are and
you're not gonna deny they're capable of
some things are not capable of other
things but so but I've been in a
situation where I based a script on a
person who was in the story and then at
the end of the draft I was like that's
not the right person for that story so I
wound up going through I called it a
major character ectomy change that that
hurt alright well actually worked out of
me I'm good okay but so yeah so
different writers have different
processes but the key for me is make it
specific as you can you don't I do have
students who'll say Joe 19 is a typical
freshman it's like there's no typical
freshman there's no typical anything
everybody's a little everybody's unique
and you look for that but so yeah that's
that's been been my experience of it
what about the science of connecting to
character right that is again something
that we dedicate a chapter to one term
that gets used that I think can limit
imagination is the idea of a hero a hero
we can't talk about the hero's journey
and then people say well if I got a hero
the connotation of a hero is someone
whose heroic someone who's likable and
does brave things that's not necessarily
what's meant by the hero's journey but
that's the connotation that people have
and the fact is that people tend to like
to watch people with flaws and you don't
want to eliminate that
you have people that aren't necessarily
admirable in fact one there we talked
about a psychologist named Jonathan
gacho has a book on this is that
that we watch characters who are flawed
because we learned from them that that
again quoting a convictive exact
psychologist who said it
he said that stories are flight
simulators for life like you can a
flight simulator so you can make
mistakes and not die and a story is
watching other people make mistakes so
you can learn to not do those things and
so it's the question of does your
character have to be likable well the
answer is it's all about what's called
the primacy effect first impressions if
they're the example of JP McMurphy okay
even the Cuckoo's Nest you howl like a
bullet is someone who's committed
statutory rape who's gets into fights
all the time it is in jail and slacks
off and doesn't want to work just wants
to play cards you tell someone no I got
this character you guys I don't want to
spend time with that character that's
who he is but when you first meet him
he's not doing those things when you
first meet him he's like being released
and he's like whooping up for joy and
then he's out there hanging out with
people and trying to encourage people
looking at their cards and things so our
first impression of him is that and that
allows us to bond with him and then as
the course of the story we get to see
his flaws come out and how they play
into the circumstance of that movie in
Bruges is the same thing you know you
would have a character who's who's a
hired killer and he killed a little kid
back said anybody still he killed a kid
and no he's he's wondering what to do
but you don't know that when you first
meet him he's like a little boy
complaining that he's stuck in this
place looking at museums and there's a
dark side to it but we get to know him
that way and then we gradually learn
about him and by then were on his side
so but the question of connecting to a
main character is what exactly happens
we talk about it again in the
there are different theories there is
this idea of course that you like a
character so you sympathize with them
but there's also a theory that you you
become the character that you literally
go through a process that one theorist
argues is the basis for morality that
you go through the process where you can
feel the pain that the other person
feels like the example given is person
decides a woman decides he's going to
murder the old man next door and then
imagines what it'd be like to be
murdered and then imagines that they are
the one being murdered feels the pain
and says no not gonna do that
so that it's more than just liking a
character it's actually a process by
which you merge and become emotionally
connected there's another I don't know
if we talked about this in the book but
there's a this notion of mirror neurons
- in the brain that them that looking at
a chocolate pie what looking at someone
eating a chocolate pie fires the same
pleasure neurons in your brain as you
eating it so that you that's not several
science I guess yet but there are strong
connections that that audiences make
with with the character that allows them
to go on this journey and and purge
themselves you know of emotion as
Aristotle said many years ago and I
think it's a this this poses a challenge
oddly enough for virtual reality because
virtual reality a few years ago they're
really struggling to come up with a way
to make it a mass consumption product
like a hit like you have jaws or Star
Wars or at the movie theater you'll have
a similar thing going on with public
theater where they're playing doing
something and the problem with that is
that you when you surrender to a movie
character you're surrendering you're not
there anymore
you stop existing now you don't have
agency you don't do anything you're just
watching it and you're enthralled and
you are it but if you're in virtual
reality you still have agency
you're not the person there you're
actually making decisions so you're
inevitably pulled out of it and bright
for a game I'm glad they haven't
developed them too far because I'd be
addicted and I'd never do anything but
play virtual reality games it's
wonderful but this process of audience
connection with a character whether it's
in movies or a storyteller is involves
real close connection and therefore
learning and you see a character go
through what we call character arc
that's when they become consciously
aware of something they didn't know
before that's a lesson they they have to
learn or you have a tragedy where the
character never learns but we learned
that they did something that they
couldn't recover from they didn't learn
in time or you get something really
twisted like Cuckoo's Nest where the
character is heroic and we don't want
him to learn we want him to always be
heroic it's just that the tragedy what
happened but something else happens so
there's there's variations
what is a dangling cause dangling cause
is one of the tools that keeps the
audience anticipating and it comes from
belief French formalism narratology the
narrative theory and the I simply stated
we we respond we talked about this them
but to cause an effect we look for cause
and effect we are geared toward
understanding the world that way and
it's easy for us to follow stories
narrative events when there is a cause
and effect it's evident dangling cause
is a cause that you don't get the effect
right away but you anticipate so boy
likes girl boy kisses girl cause of
effect
boy likes girl boy says I'm gonna kiss
her before the weekend is over dangling
comes we're gonna pick up that effect
later but it dangles over in the
audience's consciousness so it's one of
the tools in the screenwriting of the
feat the sequence approach that we talk
and that I talk about
that helps keep the audience wondering
what's going to happen next
I mentioned deadline that's one
telegraphing sort of what is coming
literally there's an appointment at five
o'clock today we're going to meet at
gerry to that area tell the audience
that when you cut there you don't have
to explain why we're there you've been
told the deadline like The Hurt Locker
or even yeah the the one American
merican Beauty we know what it's good
that when he's close to being dead it's
gonna move he's going to be over there's
dramatic irony where we are engaged
because we want to see what happens when
the truth comes out and then there's
dramatic tension which is when we're
wondering what how would the person get
what they want or not or will they
escape what they want or not and I think
if there's anything in my approach what
we're trying to do here that I emphasize
with the students is there's always talk
about rules should I follow the rule
should I break the rules should I do
this or that and to me the problem with
rules is or
understanding rules or even if you want
to call them guidelines is that if you
follow the rules congratulations you're
one down you're following you're
following you're not leading you're
following and having followed them the
rules don't applaud and they don't pay
you anything a better question asked is
what's the effect what's the effect of
my choice in the story on my audience
because now I'm one up I'm in charge of
what's happening I'm in charge of how
I'm affecting my audience and the tools
that are in these books that's the idea
what are the choices that you didn't
know you have that you have that you can
use to affect the audience and audiences
do applaud and they pay you so I like my
students to be in the power position
where they're figuring out what they
want to do rather than what whether they
can follow something so true or false if
we focus on the audience everything will
fall into place with our screenplay if
fall into place
true or false no nuance we focus on the
audience we can we have a better shot of
succeeding at connecting with an
audience that's the closest I can come
so focusing on the audience keeping
structure and mind sequences things like
that okay yep and it gives you that
freedom you know if you know what
they're anticipating you can play games
you you how do you break a rule well
Alfred Hitchcock on don't want to give
it away but Alfred Hitchcock exploited
the fact that in a Hollywood movie
there's a main character and the main
characters star and the star lives
through the movie maybe they die in the
end but they live through the movie
knowing that that's what the audience is
expecting what happens if you kill them
off 40 minutes in well that's going to
have a huge effect well but you can do
other things to make up for the loss if
you understand what the function of a
character is then you can create do
something else to compensate for that
and keep the audience interest that even
though the characters gone I'll leave
you with one joke and I know
got a and but it's it's like this if you
were to write a book knock-knock jokes
what would you do you would say you
would look at all the knock-knock jokes
you say it's very simple these are the
rules you say knock knock the other
person says who's there you give a
partial answer
they say partial answer who and then you
give them the the punchline okay that's
the rules that's my book and that's
that's how you if you want to be
successful okay knock knock oh who's
there control freak okay now here's
where you say control freak ooh see I
just broke the rules but what I was
doing was trying to elicit a laugh the
point was the effect not the rules it's
knowing what you think exploiting the
fact that you have a schema an
understanding of what a knock-knock joke
is I can play games